how does this happen and come about so
it was just Montana State University was
looking at the student debt problem and
thought well we should do something
about it so they sent you know before
anybody thought about actually running
the data here they sent a letter to
students here's a letter you don't want
to get when you're a student it begins
at Montana State University we're
serious about your education however we
want to be sure financial choices you
make do not negatively impact your
future that you know you keep reading or
maybe your parents make you keep reading
but basically it said this is the amount
you have outstanding in student debt in
order to continue receiving student debt
you need to pass sixty-seven percent of
your classes and anything more than 12
credits is free at Montana State
University and then at the end this is
perfect because there were students they
said if you go to a financial counselor
with this information we will give you
twenty dollars and that's all oh yeah
yeah I know viren might get ahead by
exactly a keen understanding of
incentives so what's amazing is what
happened after this letter went out so
the researchers at the Fed and at
Montana State compared the experience at
Montana State to the University of
Montana which did not send out letters
so they're assuming very similar
populations in state so compared to the
University of Montana this is the top
line number the next semester students
took out a third less in debt students
usually take out their full award they
took out thirteen hundred dollars less
their grades improved and they took more
credits this is amazing this is
behavioral change immediately within a
semester and it was happenstance so what
kind of role did the government place in
terms of informing the universities and
the banks informing students about their
debt load or this was just voluntary War
II so I love this there's a great quote
in the paper where they say high school
seniors generally have low exposure to
the financial system so usually the kind
of counseling you get for debt you apply
for it for a student loan and then four
years later they say by the way this is
how much you owe the second problem so
you're making lots of decisions when
you're 18 years old the second problem
is all of the academic advising you get
doesn't actually have anything to do
with money you're talking about your
major what you want to do the into our
divorce right is that you are completely
divorced the other amazing finding is
students who got this letter were more
likely to pick a stem major in the next
sem
they're starting to think about what
education is worth later on in life I
have two questions when I sort of read
about this one was thirteen hundred
dollars when you're borrowing maybe
thirty thousand dollars on average seems
like peanuts to me number one and number
two I wondered who with people who are
taking advantage of this I mean there's
gonna be lower income people who need
the full deal there's going to be the
average who are taking a little less out
where $39 actually can make a difference
I think it's significant you're talking
about a state university where tuitions
are generally lower right if you're
talking about people who are going to
Duke or somewhere on the east coast of
very expensive Ivy League I think
behavior is going to be completely
different financial awards are going to
be completely different the other thing
we know about state universities is that
tuitions have been going up because
state based aid to this to the to the
universities all over the country has
been going down so that's I mean the
kind of the answer to that question I I
also think that you know again we
usually talk about larger macro
solutions how are we going to get
colleges to bring down costs how are we
going to get you know maybe student
loans not to perversely make colleges
raise costs this study I thought was
amazing because it just talked about
micro economic behavior it's so easy and
so if you can shave just thirteen
hundred dollars off no it's not going to
solve the entire problem but that's one
piece of all these other things that we
got to talk about it also goes to to
show you how much control students do
have over their spending while they are
in school what I thought was most
fascinating was the fact that people are
choosing more stem majors yeah no more
what drama majors or you know history
majors hey it was about the narration
German major right everything useless um
yeah and I think that we're starting to
see that on a larger level of liberal
arts colleges are having a problem
antioch was closed for three years until
the alumni got together and figure out a
way to open it because you know students
on a larger level are making these
decisions they are making rational
choices now about what the value of a
college degree is again what's amazing
about this study is if you just give
them a little bit of information they're
gonna make that change the next semester
and I think the biggest part of that was
the twenty dollars they got exact go to
a financial counselor who could walk
them through how loans work I wonder
though is that going to put the onus
more on schools to provide more free
rides for people if they choose to
reduce their debt they're just not going
to have any other options I mean it
makes me wonder whether or not this was
just a pilot program it was just sort of
a good idea
they had our schools all over the
country just going to start sending a
letter it's cheap to just mail the
letter stamps though even cheaper if you
emailed a letter yeah all right Brendan
Grilli Bloomberg's senior economics
correspondent